I don't have a lot of female colleagues
it's getting better that's that's the
good news that the gradients in the
right direction it is in the at 5050 or
it isn't yet really represented
representative of the intellectual
capacity of our planet I think
engineering is probably the least
represented with a female population and
I'm not quite sure why that is because
engineering problems are phenomenally
interesting and challenging and it's a
creative profession so I think it's a
shame if women ran the world different
things would be engineered and invented
different perspectives and I think it's
a shame that we don't take more
advantage of them but I'd say set it's
getting better and it has to get better
with young men as well as young women
like one of the real challenges is if
you're a woman in science engineering
mathematics field you're overwhelmingly
likely to be married to someone else in
that kind of a field right because those
are the people you meet you're an
underrepresented population the folks
that you meet the male your male
colleagues are likely to be your
spouse's and then we have a problem what
we call the two-body problem if finding
suitable positions to jobs for one
couple in the same area that's a real
challenge and we still have a tradition
in this country where it's more likely
that if one of the two professionals
ends up sacrificing position or taking a
lesser position it's more likely to be
the women got change that
of course it's it's much easier to be
creative in terms of jobs and making
opportunities when the economy is doing
very well it's it's much harder in a
tight economy such as we have now but we
need to be creative I mean women hold up
half of the sky how can we not involve
them
well when I was getting my engineering
degree I was the only woman in a class
of 300 guys and that had a lot of
challenges had a nuclear physics course
where I was asked to leave the room the
day that they discussed health hazards
of nuclear reactors and sterility for my
male colleagues I don't know it wasn't
appropriate for a woman to sit in the
classroom and and discuss I mean as is
if I as a woman wouldn't have had any
health issues if I had gone into that
field sort of silly a lot of other
things but you know that was then and
somehow I had enough stubbornness to
make it through and gee I'm I'm
incredibly fortunate to have a career as
a scientist and be able to blend my long
ago engineering training with what I've
learned about the natural universe to
try and craft a better search program
looking for signs of someone else's
technology I mean it's really a
privilege to be a scientist first of all
you never have to grow up you never have
to stop asking why you get to pose your
own questions and try and find your own
answers and you get to do something
tomorrow that you couldn't do last week
or last month you get to learn new
things almost every day you get to learn
something new about something and gosh I
mean that's a real privilege I like to
tell young people that that being a
scientist is very much like like solving
mysteries
I mean where we're actually trying to be
the first person to understand something
other people may have worked on it
but there are problems that don't yet
have answers and we could be the first
ones to figure something out